>>> AS THE BALANCE OF POWER
BETWEEN STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS
AT AMERICA'S UNIVERSITIES HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY REVERSED.
THAT'S THE QUESTION RAISED WHEN
AN NYU ORGANIC CHEMISTRY
PROFESSOR WAS FIRED AFTER 82 OF
HIS STUDENTS SIGNED A PETITION
COMPLAINING THAT HIS COURT, A
MEDICAL SCHOOL PREREQUISITE WAS
TOO HARD.
PROFESSOR MATELIN JONES JR.
PROTECT AN INFLUENTIAL 1300 PAGE
TEXTBOOK NOW IN FIFTH EDITION
AND GARNERED MANY AWARDS.
LAST SPRING, 82 OF THE 350
STUDENTS IN HIS LARGE LECTURE
COURSE UNHAPPY WITH THEIR TEST
SCORES SIGNED A PETITION AGAINST
HIM.
IT READ IN PART WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR COURSE AND
FIND THEY'RE NOT AN ACCURATE
REFLECTION OF THE TIME AND
EFFORT PUT INTO THIS CLASS.
WE URGE YOU TO REALIZE THAT A
CLASS WITH SUCH A HIGH
PERCENTAGECH WITHDRAWALS AND LOW
GRADES HAS PALED TO MAKE
STUDENTS' LEARNING AND
WELL-BEING A PRIORITY AND
REFLECTS POORLY ON THE CHEMISTRY
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS THE
INSTITUTION AS A HOLE.
AND NYU TERMINATED DR. JONES
YEAR-TO-YEAR CONTRACT SAYING HIS
PERFORMANCE, QUOTE, DID NOT RISE
TO THE STANDARDS WE REQUIRE IN
OUR TEACHING FACULTY.
IN A GRIEVANCE PROTESTING THE
DECISION, JONES WROTE STUDENTS
WERE MISREADING AND GRADES WERE
DECLINING DESPITE HIM MAKING
TESTS EASIER AND DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHICH INVOLVED PRETESTS
AND EXAMINES, THE GRADES, QUOTE,
FELL OFF THE CLIFF.
BY THE WAY, THE ESTIMATED TOTAL
COST FOR AN NYU STUDENT
MATRICULATING FOR THIS SCHOOL
YEAR, $83,250.
JOINING ME IS A COLUMNIST FOR
CNN.COM WHERE HER LATEST IS,
THIS FIRED CHEMISTRY PROFESSOR
SHOWS WHAT'S WRONG WITH
ACADEMIA.
HE'S ALSO AUTHOR OF THE BOOK
"OKAY, BOOMER, LET'S TALK: HOW
MY GENERATION GOT LEFT BEHIND."
JILL, I WAS THINKING IF I'M THE
DEAN OF ADMISSIONS AT A MED
SCHOOL AND NOW I GET AN
APPLICANT FROM NYU, NOW, WHAT AM
I TO THINK OF THAT TRANSCRIPT?
>> I DON'T THINK IT CASTS DOUBT
ON THE INTELLIGENCE OR ABILITIES
OF NYU STUDENTS.
TO ME, THIS STORY IS MUCH MORE
ABOUT WHAT IS ACADEMIA FOR?
WHAT ARE INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
LEARNING FOR?
ARE THEY CONSUMER PRODUCTS?
OR ARE THEY PUBLIC GOODS?
AND I THINK UNFORTUNATELY, HERE
THE NYU ADMINISTRATION HAS
TREATED THE EDUCATION THAT NYU
OFFERS MORE AS A CONSUMER
PRODUCT TRYING TO PLEASE NOT
JUST STUDENTS, FRANKLY, AT THEIR
PARENTS WHO HOLD THE PURSE
STRINGS OF TUITION DOLLARS
RATHER THAN ASKING MOST
EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE FOR STUDENTS
AND MAKE SURE WE HAVE PROFESSORS
THAT ARE TEACHING EFFECTIVELY.
>> OVERWHELMINGLY, THE REACTION
THAT I HAVE SEEN TO THIS STORY
IS ONE THAT REGARDS IT AS
RIDICULOUS.
SO, LET ME GIVE YOU THE FLIP
SIDE.
THIS COMES FROM TODAY'S PRINT
EDITION OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
A PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY AT
INDIANA UNIVERSITY.
I'M GOING TO PUT IT ON THE
SCREEN BUT I'LL READ IT TO YOU
BECAUSE YOU PROBABLY CAN'T SEE.
HERE'S WHAT THE PROFESSOR SAYS,
IMAGINE, FOR EXAMPLE, A STUDENT
WHOSE HIGH SCHOOL OFFERED NO
ADVANCED CHEMISTRY CLASSES WHO
IS THE FIRST IN HER FAMILY TO GO
TO COLLEGE WHO IN ADDITION TO
HER STUDIES HAS TO WORK 20 HOURS
A WEEK TO PAY BILLS.
IMAGINE THAT THIS STUDENT
DOESN'T HAVE WI-FI OR LAPTOP IN
HER APARTMENT, SO SHE HAS TO DO
HER WORK IN A COMPUTER LAB OR ON
A PHONE.
NOW COMPARE HER TO A CLASSMATE
WHO TOOK MULTIPLE AP COURSES AND
HAS NO FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS AND
HAS AT ALL THE TOOLS HE NEEDS.
THEY MAY PUT THEM IN THE SAME
CLASS BUT THEIR BACKGROUNDS FIND
THEM MORE APART.
DO YOU FIND THAT MORE
SYMPATHETIC, ARE YOU MORE
INCLINED TO SIDE WITH THE
STUDENT IN THIS CASE?
>> I DO FIND THAT QUITE
SYMPATHETIC.
I DON'T REALLY SEE THIS AS
STUDENTS VERSUS PROFESSORS.
THE NYU STUDENT NEWSPAPER HAS A
REALLY GREAT EDITORIAL ABOUT
THIS EXACT SITUATION, WHERE THEY
GIVE A BIT MORE CONTEXT TO THE
STORY, WHICH YOU KNOW, AGAIN IS
TO SAY, THAT STUDENTS WERE NOT
DEMANDING THAT THE PROFESSOR WAS
FIRED.
WHAT THEY WERE ASKING FOR IS
MORE EFFECTIVE TEACHING METHODS.
I THINK THE TIMEPIECE THAT YOU
READ IS CORRECT THAT STUDENTS
ARE COMING TO PLACE LIKE NYU
WITH ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS.
IN AN INSTITUTION LIKE NYU WHICH
HAS INCREDIBLE NEW RESOURCES AND
HAS A MISSION TO EDUCATION
PEOPLE SHOULD BE HELPING
STUDENTS TO SUCCEED.
SOME CLASSES ARE TOUGH FOR A
REASON.
ORGANIC CHEMISTRY IS A CLASS
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO WEED
STUDENTS OUT.
BUT IF THIS PARTICULAR ORGANIC
CHEMISTRY COURSE WAS, FOR
EXAMPLE, FAILING MANY, MANY MORE
STUDENTS THAN THE OTHER ORGANIC
CHEMISTRY COURSES NYU HAS ON
OFFER, I DO THINK IT'S WORTH THE
UNIVERSITY ASKING WHY THAT MIGHT
BE.
AND TRYING TO MAKE SURE NO
MATTER WHICH SECTION THAT THE
ORGANIC CHEMISTRY STUDENTS ARE
IN, ARE GETTING A SIMILAR
EDUCATION AND QUALITY EDUCATION
AND NOT BEING HAND-HELD, AND NOT
PUNISHED, ESSENTIALLY, FOR
ENTERING IN THE WRONG CLASS.
>> WHAT WILL I LIKE ABOUT THE
STORY, HE'S AN OLD GUY HE'S 82.
GOD BLESS HIM FOR STILL TEACHING
AT THAT AGE AND BEING SO SHARP
INTELLECTUALLY WHERE HE'S ABLE
TO TEACH ORGANIC CHEMISTRY WHERE
HE WROTE THE TEXTBOOK BUT HE
PROVIDES A CONSTANT.
I'M SURE HIS GRADING HASN'T
CHANGED OVER THE YEARS.
BY THE WAY, FOR WHOM I'M
SYMPATHETIC BECAUSE OF COVID.
I NEED TO KNOW HOW YOU'RE
ANSWERING THIS WEEK'S SURVEY
QUESTION.
KATHRYN, YOU CAN PUT THAT UP ON
THE SCREEN.
HERE'S WHAT I'M ASKING PEOPLE,
WOULD YOUR CHOICE OF PHYSICIAN
BE IMPACTED IF YOU KNEW THEY
SUGGESTED WITH UNDERGRADUATE
ORGANIC CHEMISTRY?
JILL, I'M ALL FOR GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US ALL.
TRUTHFULLY, WHEN I GET A
PHYSICIAN, OR MEDICAL EXAM OR
TREATMENT, I WANT THE SMARTEST,
BEST INDIVIDUAL OUT THERE AND IF
SOMEBODY STRUGGLED FOR WHATEVER
REASON ON ORGANIC CHEMISTRY, I
DON'T KNOW, I'D BE A LITTLE
NERVOUS.
>> I MEAN, OF COURSE, ALL OF US
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
GOING INTO THE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSION ARE ABLE TO DO A
CLASS LIKE ORGANIC CHEMISTRY.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT, THERE HAS
BEEN A SHIFT IN STUDENT
PERFORMANCE IN THE LAST DECADE
OR SO.
AND PROFESSOR JONES HAS OBSERVED
THAT.
I DO THINK IT'S WORTH INQUIRING
WHY THAT IS.
JONES ALSO POINTED OUT THAT
WHILE HE HAD SEEN KIND OF A
DOWNWARD SHIFT IN STUDENT
PERFORMANCE OVER THE DECADE, AND
HE USED THE PHRASE FELL OFF THE
CLIFF DURING COVID.
THAT'S USEFUL INFORMATION TO
HAVE.
IT'S NOT UP TO NYU TO SAY, WE'RE
GOING TO LOWER STANDARDS AND
MAKE THIS EASIER FOR STUDENTS.
I DO THINK IT'S UP TO, OF
COURSE, UNIVERSITIES AND HIGH
SCHOOLS AND KIND OF DOWN THE
LINE TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
START TO REVERSE THESE CHANGES.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
EDUCATION WE'RE GIVING OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IS VERY HIGH QUALITY.
SO THAT THE REST OF US, WHEN WE
GO TO